The Joe Rogan experience was the biggest
crowd you guys ever performed in front
of him?
Um,
I think the biggest was with
Woodstock [inaudible] 94,
I think it was 93 94 and that was like
300 and 380 some odd thousand pieces.
We've done some big ones like
small European country. We,
we've done some like, you
know, like at a, you know,
100,000 people in hundred 50.
Oh my God.
I got to see this fucking
insane and that I had just cut my hair
right there. I was like, you know,
whew. Oh my God. See the
little guy next to mugs.
He was our, our, our, our uh,
our miniature knockout guy.
He knew Jujitsu, taekwondo showed Oh Khan.
He trained with, with mum, Boy Kenji.
And he was like, uh, he was like
our unofficial security. Oh,
that's hilarious. Cause Unassuming,
right? Yeah, he's a little guy.
I mean he even did,
he even did a few MMA fights.
Look at that fucking crowd.
That is insane.
I almost lost my shit right
here because you know,
seeing 300 and some odd thousand
people jumping around to your shit.
God, you know, it could
give you some equilibrium
problems. I would have seen it.
Cause it's the, it looks
like waves crashing into each
other when it's that big.
I mean that's gotta be one of the biggest
concerts ever anybody's ever performed
in front of, in North America for sure.
I mean in all of human history. Yeah.
It was one of the biggest, how
the fuck do you mean? What,
how do you get it more than
380,000 people together? Yeah.
It's crazy. That's probably only
happened a few times. It's, it's crazy.
I mean every band they had on this,
this particular bill was huge at the time.
He knows so it was,
yeah it was,
it was pretty crazy
trying to just get there.
We like some of us had
to get in through boats.
Some of us had to get in
through helicopter. Why?
Cause there's too many good cause date.
They had started parking on the roads.
Like the old school would stop and they
jammed up the highways and stuff like
that. They parked, they
pretty much shut the shit down
and I went in through helicopter and some
of the other guys went into the bloke.
That's when you know you're on top of
the world flying into a show on a fucking
helicopter and I'll tell you,
that's when you realize why you can never
get away from the cops when they're in
fucking see everything. Well,
that's a funny thing, man.
When you watch those dudes that are trying
to escape from the cops on the ground
and then you watch the
cops in the helicopter in
spotlight just stays in the car
the entire time. Yeah,
that's, yeah, that's,
and that's just a piece of it right there.
And they had a rotating stage.
What are you doing?
You have to take a shit.
How long does it take to get
from the front row to the back?
I'll take a shit tell you.
We walked around in that shit right there
and it was super muddy and crazy and
people were like, but naked with
mud all over there. Fucking bodies.
It was like people went primal.
I swear to God there they go right
there and they were having mudslides.
Um Oh man, that looks awesome. People
made babies that day in their tent.
I'm sure they did. Oh for
sure they did. Yeah, sure.
There's a lot of people out
there right now. It was, it was,
it was fucking crazy man. I
got to tell you, there was,
there was people out there totally
hippied out like straight up butt naked in
the, you know, and there was a
good portion of them. I mean not,
not in terms of the whole concert,
I mean is a small percentage,
but like you've seen just naked
people walking around free out there.
It was crazy as fuck. We
like, we're like, are we,
is this really happening?
Shit man in and then the mud was so thick,
man. It was the type where like if you
walked through it with your shoes and your
shoes weren't tight or
you weren't wearing boots,
it was sucking the shoe
right off of your foot.
It happened to me a number of times.
Hell in that show.
I jumped into the crowd cause normally
I would jump into the crowd and uh,
you know, just be floating,
you know, stage dive style.
But I would still be doing the song right.
And uh,
on that particular show they
took my shoes and socks.
I got back on stage with no
shoes and socks. And you know,
about 15 years later,
you know,
I had one guy with once you come to
the show in flicking have me sign it.
Oh.
And then the other shoe,
some or some chick had it and
had me sign it some years later.
So I've caught up with both shoes,
didn't catch up with the sites,
didn't catch up to stocks to shoes
yet. Caught up with them. What,
do they have a limited amount of
tickets for Woodstock? I mean,
what the fuck did they do when
you get that many people I take,
they probably started with the some
sort of limit and became Kay and then it
became chaos. You know, like that
something they couldn't handle.
I mean if you lived there, stretch it
to send that they want you to stuff. Oh,
I know they were pissed off. They had
a break for like fucking 25 years.
They had a break.
They sold a 164,000 tickets,
but the crowd estimated size was 550,000.
Okay, well shit, I was too short.
It's 200,000 short. Yeah. Yeah,
because the rest rush, the gate,
you know,
they took the fence and you know,
to sit down and they just fucking rolled,
rolled on it. I would imagine that it,
you know, cause went into an event
that everybody wants to get to.
They're going to find a way to it and
it's outside and it's outside and what
those numbers, man, that's, you can't
stop that. I'm now in it, you know, it's,
it's a great part of their
history because I mean, you know,
that one was a good one where no
one got hurt and there was no crazy,
uh, no crazy shit happening. Like
the next one after that, I mean,
they had some habitat x one. Ah,
well shit, they had a bunch of,
uh, women say that they had gotten
raped or molested at, um, at,
at the one the following
year. Um, and, uh,
fires that shit at the end.
Yeah. And then there was fires.
There was a whole bunch of people
lost their fucking mind, the one,
and that's so great bands too. So, you
know, they don't do that anymore. Right.
What stocks know that there's the summer,
they're doing it enough.
What are you doing? You fucking idiots.
Move. Sell your house. Yeah. Do something.
Do something. It's crazy though, because
there's a fire is holy shit man. Yeah.
They had bonfires. Yeah. I believe
when little Ms. Good corn went on,
it was either limp Bizkit or corn
and the fires just fucking started.
People were pissed because they were
charging so much for water and like,
they couldn't, they couldn't get to the
bathrooms like you're asking like theirs,
they didn't have the facilities
set up as well or yeah.
They didn't have adequate facilities for
what, what the fuck was popping to me.
And you know, uh, you
know, a spouse is Christ.
Look at the fucking what it looks
like after it's over. Listen,
a thousand Andy gumps for
500,000 people is nothing
you imagined you need like 10,000.
He could imagine being the dude
who gets in there after 5,000.
I mean look at taking a shit.
They totally took over the fucking the
highway rat racey they shut down the
fucking highway. They just parked their
cars. Yeah, they made the highway.
The parking is crazy. Look at that.
At least it was kind of orderly.
Like maybe they sort of sort of, they
shut down. I'll tell you this though.
They weren't cold blooded. Um,
the, the organizers because
that is so crazy.
These guys had some fucking Moxy, I'll
tell you that. Hey listen, you know,
after every band was done with their set,
they expected you to leave right away
because the next wave of bands was coming
and they were getting your spot.
So like if you had a dressing room,
once you're set was done,
you were expected to get the fuck out.
So you've got a helicopter out of there.
If, if, yeah, it was best if you did,
because if you didn't take the ride
when, when, when you were supposed to,
you were getting stuck there,
they couldn't guarantee that they could
give you the ride back to your shit
after that,
you know,
because they had all the other bands to
think of and they might not have room
for you when they take the other
bands. So it was like, yeah,
that fucking fish. Oh
my God. Yup. Oh my God.
Yes. That's what we look at.
It looks like Caitlyn, Mike,
it's like PAC man fucking eating
the stage. Right. That's insane.
That picture is insane.
Yeah, it was. That's, that's,
that's the one I'll remember the most. I
mean, we've, we've done some huge gigs,
but like that one by far,
you know,
never have we played for another 500,000,
sound like 500,000 people screaming
much like that Viking chant.
I mean,
we had a small nation right there with
crazy legitimately like when you leave
there and then you go do a regular
gig afterwards. Does it feel weird?
He, uh, well it depends,
but yeah, adjusting.
It does take some adjusting,
you know,
especially if the next Gig is in
his hype is that you're like, fuck,
we just came from Woodstock.
But fortunately the smaller
gigs that we had after that,
you know, in terms of planning
festivals, they were like, you know,
in between 30,000 and seventy
thousand one hundred thousand.
And we felt that that gave us such an
experience that we can handle any fucking
stage. So it became easier for
us to do festivals after that.
And the reaction that we would get at
these festivals were smaller versions of
what we did there, you
know? And uh, it was,
it was a great experience because we had,
we had been doing like a,
a couple of European
festivals before that,
so it sort of prepared us for
that. But we didn't, we didn't,
I mean, the fucking numbers we were
definitely not prepared for. We were like,
Whoa, what the fuck? That's like that
transcends reality. Yeah. I mean,
listen, we know that that's not our show.
They're not all there for us, you know,
cause it's a mixed bag,
right?
A bunch of different artists and you're
winning over people. If anything you're,
you're, you're, you're there
playing for your, your,
your base of people that
might've come to see you,
but you're winning everybody else over
if you're doing it right. And, uh,
for us it was like a, a victory
because we saw, you know,
half a million people up there jumping
up and down the all our shit and they
knew the words and they were singing
with us and it, you know, it was like a,
a big notch under the belt in
a boost for our confidence,
knowing that we can get
in front of anybody,
play with anyone and get that reaction.
I mean,
because after that, you know, we
were getting booked on metal, um,
driven festivals and stuff.
Where were the only hip hop on it,
but it's all straight up metal.
I mean we were playing shows, um,
co headlining under Metallica,
right? Metallica, Cypress Hill,
um, uh, biohazard, def
tones, fear factory in,
in all of that stuff. You know what
I mean? And we'd be in that mix,
playing those festivals with those guys
and with hip hop music and you know,
the boost did, it gave us in
the confidence, it was like,
fuck that we can play with
any of these motherfuckers.
It doesn't matter who it is.
And,
and we went to those metal fest metal
festivals with our hip hop and got metal
reaction, mosh pits, stage dives,
everything what you know,
and,
and it felt good to be able to hang
up there with Metallica. I mean, yeah,
what they do to a crowd is crazy.
But we realized that if we were playing
on the same venue going before them,
we can in a festival form,
we can fucking hang with anyone.
And, and uh, that's,
that pretty much put us over the top
with doing festivals. Like, yeah,
we're going to fucking rule this shit.
People are going to have to,
people are going to have to up their game
when we're on that festival with them.
That's the way we took it.
And I would imagine you couldn't
sleep for days after that chair.
The adrenaline was crazy.
I got to tell you,
the adrenaline was crazy and then
you're in the helicopter leaving.
Will you like what the fuck does happen?
Yeah, we were, we were tripping out man.
I mean,
we were like totally in awe of,
of the response that we got
and the, the, the, you know,
the enormity of the fucking crowd,
man. I mean it was fucking huge.
Is to be a part of something.
That's that, I mean,
that's like something that no
one there is ever gonna Forget.
We took it for granted. I've got to
tell you when we fucking, they'll, well,
they want you to do well. Okay. We'll do
Woodstock, whatever. And, and, and uh,
when we got there, that's when we
saw just how fucking crazy it was.
I think this is yet, see, oh, this is
you. So they steal your shoes. Yeah,
they're good. Yeah, they're good. They're
going to start coming. Watch that.
I have to hold my shirt forward
so they don't get choked out.
And there goes,
there goes the first shoes.
Take that first one. Yeah. Ridiculous.
What were you thinking when
they were taking shit? Like,
Damn. I was like, Oh fuck.
There goes once you there
goes on white sock. Yeah.
That goes the other so ridiculous.
And there is no fucking security that
can stop 500,000 people and save all that
shit.
No,
you're at the mercy of the fans but he's
going to grab from my sock pretty soon.
That is so wild. And is stealing socks.
Look at it. It's still your parents.
Hey listen, you know they, they,
they tried in big grabby Dick. No.
You know, they tried to grab the weed
in my pocket. Ah. Is that sometimes,
you know, when your adrenaline is
kicking you're not really thinking,
you know what's in my pocket and
shit like that. But yeah. You know,
throughout the, I had chicks
trying to grab my shit for
sure. Of course. The, sure.
Yeah. That was a little, you know, crazy
for me, you know? But it is what it is.
If you're going to stand close. Yeah. You
know, Shit like this happens, right? Yeah,
man.
I mean if,
if you're going to stage dive you got
to assume some weird shit is going to
happen. Yeah. I mean for me, you know,
people were mostly respectful, you know,
but they would go through my pockets to
see if I had weed in one gravity or your
pockets out. Yeah, I did. I had some,
I had like an ounce of weed in one at
one show and I jumped in and I totally
forgot I had it in my pocket.
Boom. If I can took my Goddamn, we
hope you enjoyed that. I bet
they did. Actually. They did
their role in that joint.
This is be real weed, man. I know
they do train from California.
This is the real shit.